once upon a time there was a boy who was
born into a family of simple tailors in
the middle of sub-Saharan Africa the
boy's father wanted him to continue the
family business but the boy wanted a
better life and one night decided to
leave his home and go to Europe
to cross the sea the boy built himself a
raft but once he left the shore there
was only a little wind and it didn't
take long for his supplies to run out
and there he was hungry and lonely
floating in the middle of the
Mediterranean Sea imagine you live on
the coast of southern Europe and one
morning read about the boy's fate in a
local paper should you yourself try to
save him
four influential philosophers Aristotle
Mill cant and Nietzsche can help us
answer this and other difficult moral
questions with their respective theories